hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
now we've got one called Sophie which is
probably about a creepy little girl that
is a ghost or possessed or in some way
bad so we're gonna find out which one of
those alternatives it is and get into
the game the rules are simple enough
some things are triggered by your gaze
other by player interaction you need to
use your wits to escape your environment
whoa I don't have a lot of those we
don't want to spoil too much here's a
few hints look closely at everything but
not everything in the matters well
remember you can use your e key to
interact with certain objects and yes
the game can be beaten at some point the
answer is right in front of you okay
this looks great
hey Sophie is this your uh is your thing
I'm gazing at it I'm pumping it full of
all my gaze nothing okay
alrighty then nobody here hello no you
or doing my excuse my oh the door oh I
was looking at the wall I hear a
squeaking door I automatically look at
the wall cuz I'm none too smart
alright well nevermind then oh it's one
of those games one of those changing
games so why am I so low on the screen
there's a whole there's all 3/4 of his
screen that's not taken up why is my
flashlight so low yeah are you doing hey
how you doing hey how you doing hey how
you doing hey how you doing hey how you
doing whoa someone learned acrobatics
how you doing hey what's your doing hey
how you doing
okay I won't be here anymore where will
I be well get out oh I'm trying I'm
trying to get out that's like my
objective that's like the whole point of
the game all right whatever what have
you got for me
Merc Merc ABBA
what happened did I look too closely at
Merkava Sophie or Coppa James Nadia
anybody here somebody drop their coat
might somebody make a drawing of the
flux capacitor from Back to the Future
oh that's a fun one no I like that guy
hey how you doing hey how you doing hey
how you doing well these kids sure are
drawing real good art please no okay yes
sure is the thing okey oh that's yeah
that makes so much sense can I have that
can I has that can I have that is that a
smudge on my screeners at the dot and I
asked that hello
No okay well I guess looking at that key
did absolutely dick and diddly okay Oh
Oh Sophie whoa Sophie
all right Sophie you uh-oh it's a
combination of all the it's a
combination of all the symbols okay I
don't know what I'm supposed to be doing
about this but I'm looking looking real
closely at this okay yes no bombs
clunk he
[Music]
haha that's nice is a big deal it's not
a big deal at all
ain't nothing that ain't nothing stopped
me nothing you ain't nothing you know
nothing you do nothing you have nothing
can I pick this goddamn goddamn key up
no okay fine then
so still Sophie's not crossed out does
that mean I need to do something mmm the
cooler a [ __ ] air heckum cooler become
clear haggle stamp I am ultimately very
confused Oh screw you you children's
Arts I'm gonna get you yes will you oh
[Music]
it's the wrong one well that's what
you're saying all creepy-like all right
I get it
now I understand okay Ruby no Rishon yes
give me that listen I don't want to call
you a sack of [ __ ] cuz that's mean but
I'm gonna call you a sec [ __ ] if you
keep doing that to me
alright so what about the ones that
aren't on here Ruby now you ain't nothin
Claudia you're on there no it's gonna be
a certain order or something right oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa hey now don't be
like that
what did i do did I do good I think I
did good okay I think I did good
hey will James James is the man right
okay got James
[Music]
Hey whoa whoa whoa why what'd that
happen why'd you do that to me why would
you do that why'd you kill me I'll skip
this you use my wits huh got those I got
big old bag of rocks that's what I got
oh hello
squeakily weakly squiggly dickly okay so
we shown no no no no no so what about
swoo weird something well Sophie Sophie
no Sophie no use
Sophie no get use maybe I need to touch
that probably thunk all right Sophie no
well I'm at loss I'm at my big brain
okay I get that that was the wrong one
but I also don't understand because I
was punished for what seemed like the
right ones and I died okay so what did
that do it tore one down Oh Oh what what
really really I just got I could have
done that I didn't know I didn't know I
couldn't I didn't know I could have done
that at any moment at any juncture oh
you seen nothing whoosh alright so is
this what I'm supposed to be doing
because it seems like if I do too many
of these I'm thumbs are gonna die moms
are gonna die real bad da-dew okay think
about this logically big ol mark brain
come on think brain come on I'm talking
to your brain in my head come on think
about this it's just a simple puzzle so
a simple puzzle is as simple as a puzzle
can be so if you really take two plus
two and you make it for when the lesson
is over you're gonna be on the floor
open the door get on the floor everybody
do the dinosaur right
[Music]
apparently I'm not right you say wrong
one
and yet you killed me when I supposedly
got the right one so I think it's
sending a lot of mixed signals here well
it is just a big old bag of stupid ain't
it I'm talking about myself I am a big
old bag of stupid according to everybody
yeah okay I get it wrong one yeah what
else do you want from me I can't
I'm not these symbols are too smart boy
I wish I had a big brain
maybe if I gotta go outside in and maybe
figure outside in I don't see the wool
maybe James James James taller I got it
I'm a smarty so we are going outside in
on this bad boy aren't we that's the
general juxtaposition of what I'm
getting huh so if it's outside it's got
to be this wrong one apparently it was
very obviously the wrong one
maybe I gotta unlock the outer circles
of it nope
mmm Oh maybe because that's upside down
maybe it's representative of the smaller
one and what I need is the bigger one
right here nope
wrong one this'n oh oh that doesn't
sound good
I don't know what that is but it's not
good oh oh hi
oh hello ah 98 good old nine zero oh you
know you don't have to 82 Oh am I on a
timer here oh no I am aren't I okay so
circle through that or this and Nadia
Nadia got it okay Nadia and then no I
don't know this is complicated all right
here we go Anna Anna perfect all right I
don't know why you're being them I don't
want to deal with whatever it was
happening behind me but okay got it all
right now I need the pointy goober
dabber that doesn't seem like a lot of
time left you hey how you doing oh hey
how are you doing I'm I'm assuming I
shouldn't shouldn't go near any of you
please don't go Mike so badly I want to
breathe the sweet dough hey you're um
mm-hmm
see this is a problem uh hallucination I
should have known all right do I have
enough time to finish this oh the ring
now the good old blue well that's not
much time
excuse me I do need this ring here okay
and then we scot-free as far as the eye
can see I'm free no no oh
the glorious bright shining light of
death all right that was that was
interesting
the mechanics not a hundred percent sure
about but it was not too bad
moderately scary you have enough five
spooks out of eleven there you go
next all right so this one is called
it's not there
where is it where is it oh there it is
this one's called creeper on the 3rd of
o on the 3rd of September a serial
killer named Denver kidnapped three
people too much reverb rumor has it that
he keeps them in his five million dollar
mansion in the outs sources confirmed
that a videotape of a kidnapping is
stashed in his basement unfortunately
the video has been split in multiple
parts your objective is to place the
clips in the right order and render the
video this will help us catch Denver and
punish him for the crimes he committed
to be careful
clicking render 4 times when the video
is not in the correct order will trigger
a local lockdown and Denver will up to
you good luck agent there's a weird
mission I gotta admit Bosley this this
one ain't to Bosley
Charlie's and Charlie Charlie Bosley I
don't remember who huh
but there is get him okay here anything
am I am I supposed to not hear anything
okay what is this this is nothing this
is a whole lot of nothing at this he's
climbing a tree which makes sense I
guess
some dude with a bag and then this'n
render I did it authorities arrived on
scene and arrested the killer it's trial
for murder of the three people will be
held in December the murder is notice
our unknown is there supposed to be
sound to this there was sound here what
hold on to your dicks what
I can't even skip this what's happening
wave for some years ago with the sound
go put it in windowed mode yeah put it
in windowed mode yeah there we go this
will work now I guess it's just there
there's some music is dramatic wait hang
on
a serial to an Indian that didn't leave
a purple room reservation Simpsons 500
dollar mansion in the Alps sources
confirm the diminutive taken nebulous
cash and his basement unfortunately the
video had been split into multiple
warrants your objective is to place
exclusive design right ordered in under
the video this was mail post captain
the parentheses
[Music]
gonna be all fun fun games
[Music]
alright so still no sound are you know
running around around around or under
he's got me he's got me by the balls I
think does he got me danver all sound
whoa
I'm assuming I'm dead am i dead
I might be dead oh and now there's sound
a serial killer named Kendrick donor
hazard 75 another man in the house
stalked and his department
unfortunately the fire was a split and
emotional hurts your objective is to
close the clothes right either right or
and ran in a video that's what I'll ask
a stander and punishing foreign crows is
promoted Oh careful taking Randy evolved
I will track down and capture go-go-go
ah still no still no sound you sure you
sure footsteps you wanna run the
footsteps by me again okay let me put
them in the right order and then let's
just watch this video because they
obviously put some work into this and I
don't want it to I don't want to [ __ ]
all over just because my audio settings
are a little goofed oh hey buddy hey now
see that's creepy that's real creepy I
like that like you wherever you are
you're nice I like you you're you're
real nice hey see that's creepy what
couldn't that have been there from the
start okay play let's see this bad boy
it's nor tried different tree yeah yeah
I mean we have what are they doing dude
look it's like bad yeah
No
you'll holy [ __ ] that's the person
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you will be climbing trees anymore Billy
nah you too tree climbing scoundrels are
never gonna see the light of day again
those hilarious probably wasn't meant to
be hilarious but I found a hilarious
cuz it was very reminiscent of pretty
much everybody going into the woods
filming and finding a murderer
hello murderer anyway good game little
silly I like it though the concept is
nice it just needs to refine next is
something wrong where is the game it
just doesn't want to load okay all right
then well I guess we're not gonna play
that one let's do Oh Oh the game it's
here welcome to burglary I gave up I was
actually going off to download another
game but I guess I don't have to now so
good all right great
oh hello my name is markiplier and I'm
here to burgle I'm gonna burgle up all
your goodies much stuff um of my
burgling bag yeah you better believe I
can fit a lot of junk in my trunk my
burgling trunk something tells me if I'm
here to burgle something no good Oh some
no good fate is about to befall me I'm
probably going to be haunted by many
demons for my misbegotten ways ooh that
looks expensive joint steel yes please
i burgled it right out of here anything
to burgle in the basement the basement
of Burghley burglary burgles
Oh No hello is this burglar boo can i
burgle anything you'd think if they
would have something valuable in the
basement don't mind me
your friendly neighborhood burglar just
passing through looking for burglar
obols
okay guess nothing's in the basement the
Bergland basement ral oh I don't exactly
remember there being more house here but
okay
what is that so I'm trying to sneak up
on the burger
it's impossible can't be done impossible
hello
okay oh there no oh you click on them
interact date it's quick no I didn't
know that all right here we go oh wow oh
yes blaze a burgle more burglar bulls
hello toilet Bergland no Bergland hello
faucet Bergland what is this burglar
crown what is that I don't care it's
mine
my burgled it's I think it might have
been a ring or possibly a spleen or
something but it's mine now in my bag of
burgles right hello burgled pillow
burgled stains I think I've got pretty
much everything that's Berg Louisville
Myrtle that TV away my bag hey hey how
you doing watch of course i'll burgle
that's right anything else I think I
have to have burgled everything oh I can
know I was here I was being a fool in
the dark like an [ __ ] forget so I'll
be on my way got enough burgles in my
bag
I shan't not need stay longer right yeah
I'd be sure dumb of me to stay too long
let's go back in the burgling basement
because there's got to be like a light
or something that I can turn on down
here I'm back baby back and ready to
burgle Lou who secret secrets tried to
keep your secret's safe from me I think
not I'm here to go ahh a basement in a
basement you thought that would protect
your valuables from the burglar no I say
there's some interesting architecture
you got going on here it's like
brutalist gothic or whatever it's lovely
valuables wait hang on
hold the phone I was just here now the
lights don't work oh well I think that
maybe
I think they're maybe not Oh someone
what a bastard they knocked over a chair
but hey this is like my heaven I get to
burgle till the ends of my days nothing
can stop the Bergling hello burglar
balls I get to put it right back in my
bag the joy of burgling never ends no
watch here to burgle must be somewhere
else
no ah me he-hey Oh a epic that thank you
all right hello hi how are you oh the
basement I'll come back Lee to do burgle
the basement and then the beyond
basement in the bottom of the basement
but for now I'm content to burgle
upstairs or downstairs cuz I'm already
been upstairs
this is did not it's not up it's down
all down from here pretty much just like
me okay I think I got everything all
right
down into the basement la dee da dee da
here I go to pep-pep at pip pap hello
lights camera burgle hello can I have
something ah it's open might I be on an
endless loop I think that maybe I might
be yay great closed not yet closed very
closed okay
closed closed no closed closed
yes closed okay good good dee dum drop
us you know a lifetime of Bergling anus
appealing as I once thought it might be
but last you know the old Bergland bones
they get a little old and rusty over
time why not let it just why not let it
go quit while you're ahead
why not quit while your burglar Lou my
Bergland limbs are still working Oh
wiser where's the grass and there's a
guy where's our grass in the sink I
can't burgle that all right downstairs
here we go there was less to burgle I
didn't get the clock it's almost as if
life loses all meaning when there's
nothing this is different I don't like
change
oh boy a fresh new day oh they're losing
chairs some other person is boggling all
their chairs how are they gonna sit
there tired took assists down the answer
is it they're not who not alone I don't
like the title of that book
I don't like books in general just don't
trust them don't trust the way they look
at you I'm judgmental from the shelf
maybe they'll make myself at home
oh I don't like the eyes on that pillow
well I'm taking this and you can judge
me all you want so shut up small pillow
Salazar drink okay George your big
pillow bunky whatever go away
I don't yeah I don't need you judging me
I don't need that kind of energy I don't
need that vibe you need to you're
harshing my yard my vibe oh this is
growing that's good that's good that's a
good thing is real good I'm glad I went
here I'm glad I'm a burglar I'm glad I
far gold this particular home of death
and despair you see it's really my greed
that's getting me I can't stop burgling
so I keep going down it's really a sad
tale what is that nothing it's a whole
lot of nothing it's uh a whole lot of
nothing you got eyes up to all that
small pillow Salazar right there you
don't think you're gonna get me I'm too
fancy to be got um ungettable you will
not burglar the burglar you'll not
burgle the burglar
hello
oh wait a minute have I finally grown
taller this always seems smaller I'll
take that you wink everything's smaller
here I must have finally a puberty from
the biggest burglar around ain't nobody
gonna stop me now whoa hello hi how are
you Oh Dora there that I didn't notice
before I'm still gonna try to burgle
everything possible you know how it is
with Bergling in my bones and in my
jeans burling's in my blood as they say
remind my Bloods probably gonna be out
of my body very soon ah good old closet
bed I bet Harry Potter lived here there
still for us growing in here no my
veranda
I think if bran is a type of porch I
don't think it's actually a type of
plant line I'm probably wrong on that
one but nobody correct me if I'm wrong
okay
suddenly I'm hearing noises from a
cavalcade of silence I'm suddenly
hearing noises where you go what is this
a little trashy so not much left to
burgle but I better buy our way out now
go call my riches somewhere hello hello
oh ah
okay well this is definitely a thing
that's happening right now don't you
look at me you [ __ ] okay and away we
go yeah the architecture seems to be
slipping a little bit I don't I say you
cut the budget down here below the the
surface but you might have done it a
little bit done a little bit better oh
boy here we go again
hello you're all out of chairs oh it's
back to normal
I hear the rain again wait what oh no
the chairs are back good that's a good
thing can you tell me if that's good
that I'm taking this you Inc okay I'm
joint joint okay what else can I join I
don't know why I'm suddenly here in the
rain again I assume that can only mean
that I'm about to escape this with my
life intact is that can only be a good
thing the rain coming closer and closer
joint hello Oh
plants well it's been fun I'm super
happy that I experienced this and it's
quiet again not a hundred percent sure
why but it's quiet again just gotta be
something soon it's gotta be something
soon what is the endgame here
what is the deal am I just gonna be
doing this for all eternity whoa one
final bargainable you bet your sweet ass
must steal that what's here what's this
huh who's here
somebody here for you Oh what the what
the what the [ __ ] is that just a trick
of the light did I see a face that might
have just been that plant and that thing
looking like a face at a certain angle
but I could have sworn I saw a face yeah
do a close-up zoom of that face when
there's definitely a face there and if
there's a professor see there was a face
a horrible face an ugly face disgusting
on every level imaginable no face worse
than that face that I saw right there
that was disgusting don't wear it no I
don't know where I'm going Oh
Oh drink well I don't I don't I'm having
trouble here my my little brain ain't
ain't understanding this place too good
but so long as that got burglar bulls
I'm a happy camper uh oh no no let's not
go down there just yet I mean I imagine
I'll have to go down there eventually oh
it's the big room of what was that what
was that why is that
well is that it's the face oh I don't
like that oh okay you Inc my shins
they're dead okay Bertil Yoink let me
out of this hell because I burgled too
deeply i burgled with my own sanity away
please
I just want to burgle can't i burgle in
peace must I give up my Bergling I guess
I must then considering I'm not making
any progress
hmm what what am I looking at what am I
looking at exactly it's deep horizon
into nothingness with blue a little
touch of blue oh hey a little touch of
weird on the wall of concrete which has
evolved a little bit which I appreciate
that like like like things growing like
content develop or character development
that's nice okay you bye bye legs okay
and Link and K and M hmm but there's
gonna be more to burgle here and there
and everywhere and burglar bulls I'm
trying to go a slightly different way
just to mix it up a little bit ah it's a
concrete room oh it's amazed
I love Meru don't mind if I forego how
do I get out of here I guess I gotta go
around don't I fine I tried to go a
different way but then it bit me in the
tit my sacs getting real hefty just so
you all know my big sack is full to
bursting with burglar Bulls can I get
out of here can I get out of here please
please pretty please see you Inc okey
dokey ba okay
well this is different I can't say that
everything's been very different this
whole time ah okay okay okay I don't see
any more burglar bulls it's all just a
bunch of nothing now whereas the burglar
bulls what's the point of even being
trapped in hell if it were if you can't
burgle for all eternity okay long
hallway
I don't trust long hallways I'm always
always lead to death this is not correct
geometry this this this is not right dan
st. hang on a second
I mean I'm definitively going in a big
luau I don't have to poop I'm pretty
sure I'm being dict with I'm dive a good
feel I've got like a spider sense about
me and dict with the chairs are judging
me and I think I think I think I've got
a shear case of Ditka tree gone on air
the hell it can only be matched by an
incredible ability to burgle oh I don't
trust long hallways I don't I just don't
I just don't so if you could not do any
of whatever you're doing that'd be
greatly appreciated that would be
wonderfully appreciated you got us the
blue hey blue hey Geronimo okay all
right well so I got used to pick blue oh
[ __ ] know what what I was it all my
burgling how am I going straight to hell
was it because of all the things that I
just did burgle a [ __ ] I deserve this
okay
we I'm in hell how it's lovely I don't
know what this game is about I don't
know what this games on I don't know
what this game is doing I don't know
his game is far I don't know what that's
all about what do you guys there hole in
the wall I can burgle my way out of here
if I burgle the bricks in the wall they
can't keep me caged up
no I'm unstoppable oh good boy why this
just don't make sense it don't make
sense yeah I don't like to get out now
I'd like to be free and out and I would
like to be out and I would like to be
free I would like to be free and I would
like to be out I would like to be free
and out Oh
burgle
ah [ __ ] nothing left a burgle alright oh
[Music]
[ __ ] oh boy ow again my okay well I'm in
the basement again
great do I have all my [ __ ] do I still
have all my burglar bulls I'll burgle
your soul my burger you're so right out
of your body you don't even think about
it
don't even think about it
you
well that was burglar burglary murk
glory burglary that was burglary
we burgled I bet there's multiple
endings that one I got the endless fall
ending great thanks if you want more
scary games let me know what scary games
you want me to play in the next three
scary games in the comments down below
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]